[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein schönes brot das ist kein
klassisches brot sondern eins ohne hefe
ich habe mir gedacht viele von euch
haben es gerade keine hefe da aber
backpulver habt ihr da ich hab extra
eine umfrage gestartet und die meisten
ich glaube über 90 prozent von euch
haben backpulver zu hause daher zeige
ich euch jetzt das schnelle und einfache
rezept für backpulver braucht ihr auch
keine ruhezeit also ist es auch wirklich
sehr schnell sie mit erst mal meinen sie
und mein mail und beziehe ich das immer
eine große schüssel und ich nehme heute
dinkelmehl typ 630 ihr könntet auch
weizen medien das ist auch kein problem
[Musik]
wir wollen ja nichts verschwenden wie
ist nämlich ein luxusgut grünzeug soll
dazu gebe ich jetzt backpulver und auch
das salz verrühren das ganz kurz
miteinander und dann habe ich hier noch
die folgenden zutaten joghurt wenn jetzt
kein joghurt ab dann nimm einfach milch
dann habe ich mineralwasser mit
kohlensäure so ein kleiner geheimtipp
und etwas öl und das verstehe ich jetzt
alles mit den händen
[Musik]
und ein bisschen es sich weil wir keine
hefe haben das gibt nochmal so diesen
sauren geschmack
[Musik]
zu den teig dann auf der arbeitsfläche
weiter kneten nicht lange gerade so eine
minute und wenn euch mail fehlt gibt auf
jeden fall noch ein bisschen was dazu
aber auch nur so viel dass es gerade so
nicht mehr klebt und dann schnappen wir
uns unsere kasten kuchenform besprühen
die ordentlich mit back transpower
alternativ gerne öl nehmen und dann den
boden mit einer lust kern mischung aus
streuen das ist zwar optional aber ist
einfach nur lecker so und jetzt gebe ich
den teig einmal länglich drängen drücke
noch so ein bisschen flach oben und
jetzt schnappt ihr euch einfach
leitungswasser gibt es obendrauf und da
kommt jetzt auch noch mal die nuss kern
mischung obendrauf und anschließend
schneidet mit dem messer einmal in der
mitte ganz leicht ein bisschen was ein
[Musik]
so und jetzt kommt unser zauber brot
einfach in den vorgeheizten backofen
unteres drittel ganz wichtig 200 grad
ober unterhitze dass der ofen schon
ordentlich heiß ist und dann packte ihn
so lange bis er innen auch da ist falls
euch oben zu dunkel wird einfach mit
alufolie abdecken und weiter backen und
wir sehen uns dann nachher für den
anschnitt nach 35 minuten ist mein
zauber brot jetzt fertig jetzt stellt
sich das einmal kurze lang ist noch warm
ist ich zeig euch jetzt auch ein trick
wie ihr erkennt also generell ob euer
brot durch ist und zwar knopf jetzt
einfach auf die rückseite wenn sich das
hole anhört dann ist es durch kandera
mit dem mikro sowie marco genau so und
jetzt könnt ihr das luftdicht verpackt
bis zu mehrere tage lagern
es schmeckt auch lauwarm im allerbesten
da könnt ihr jetzt butter und käse und
wurst cetera drauf geben und einfach nur
genießen ich hoffe dass euch das video
gefallen hat macht unsere gehen und das
ohne hefe also das muss man dafür tun
dass jetzt so hübsch aus unbedingt
nachmachen und ihr braucht summa
summarum 40 minuten mit backzeit und das
ist echt super also ganz viel freude
beim nachbacken und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten rezept hierzu
[Musik]